but we're gonna begin with this images
of hunters celebrating their trophies
often draw widespread support and
condemnation test tally knows this
firsthand we are hearing from her today
for the first time since this photo of a
giraffe she killed in South Africa in
2017 prompted worldwide outrage that
outrage has not stopped her from going
on more trophy hunts Adam Yamaguchi of
our CBS n originals unit followed tally
as she tracked a wildebeest on a
wildlife ranch in Texas take a look good
they don't go down easy all the time
Tess isn't just any trophy hunter this
is where we take the pictures okay you
ready not long ago a picture just like
this made test infamous perfect and
turned her life upside down an American
hunter is pushing back against her
critics in 2017 she killed the giraffe
and in the summer of 2018
the picture she posted went viral a part
of the black dress that I shot black due
to old age something that I could take
around with me and have him with me on
all my hunt I got the gun case made now
have decorative pillows made out of him
and everybody loves them so tell me
about that dress he really was not only
what's he beautiful and majestic he was
he was good and we all take pictures
with our harvest yeah so what we do it's
what they've always done there's nothing
wrong with that Anne Tolley joins us now
test good morning let's go right to this
picture that it has cost so much outrage
when many people will see that picture
of you in front of the draft they see a
pointless killing a cruel killing and
not only that they see an American woman
posing for a picture smiling and seeming
to take glory and celebration a sense of
pride in what many people see as a
murder right what do you see in that
picture I see it as it's a hover you
know it's something that I love to do
it's conservation at this hunt print in
particular was conservation hunt and
that's rife when it leads word toast
what does that mean come we are
preserving the wildlife
so what we do is we take out like we are
managing her it's were managing numbers
of wildlife and we're hunters and we're
proud to be a hunter I am proud to hunt
and I'm proud of that dress
you say it's about conservation but the
smile the the clip we just saw it seems
like there's a lot of pleasure and it -
a lot of joy but yeah you do what you
love to do you know it's joy if you
don't enjoy it you're not gonna continue
to do it
you also said remorse though and that
stands out to me if there's the force
why do it yes well it's you know
everybody thinks that the easiest part
is pulling the trigger and it's not
that's the hardest part but you've
gained so much respect and so much
appreciation for the animal because you
know what that animal is going to they
are put here for us you know we harvest
them we eat them and it's not just us
you know I am okay with providing for my
family and my friends with me wild game
meat which is fabulous but I'm also okay
with providing meat across the globe
when you depend on that when you talk
about there they are here for us to
enjoy to see yeah yeah once they're
killed though that takes it away from
others being able to see if it's about
conservation why not put the money that
you'd put towards a big game hunt
towards just conservation so others may
see that that animal yes I would rather
do what I love to do rather than to just
give a lump sum of cash somewhere and
not know particularly where that is
going we've reported on this broadcast
and others have as well that the the
money from conservation hunting as you
describe it is a paltry sum compared to
wildlife tourism so the argument isn't
the strongest if you say joy you say you
enjoy it that I understand the
conservation part doesn't add up it's
tough it's a science it's really hard
I'm not a conservationist I'm a hunter
so I do my part
conservationists needs us hunters if you
do find them if you knew it didn't lead
to conservation would you still do it
just knock down animals just to be
knocking them down in it and I hoping
anything No
if this is about conservation and about
helping wildlife why the picture for
your Facebook page why the celebration
of the death that's the hardest thing
test I have to say that for me too
looking at the picture the the Glee you
appear to take out of it and then to see
you with the the carrying case and the
pillows that just seems
that seems to go beyond sport to me help
us understand exactly what it means to
you the pictures are a tradition that
hunters have done long before social
media when social media came around
that's when there was an issue that's
when people started a backlash gene and
they had surprised did the reaction that
you got from posting those pictures I
kind of was surprised yeah I really
wasn't expecting things to go crazy as
they did I was posting that for myself
my friends and my family and the tons of
like-minded people that I associate with
and communicate with on social media how
bad did it get for you oh it got really
bad I receives mails at my house they're
spreading out to addresses where they
think that I may be they were showing up
at my work they're calling my employer
trying to get me fired I have a great
employer and he supports me all the way
and you're still hunting absolutely all
right test tally thank you very much for
all right trophy hunting killing or
conservation is part of our documentary
series cbsn originals it is streaming
right now on CBS news.com slash hunting
[Music]